this is the least attracted to you I've
ever been
[Music]
hello I'm rural hi I'm Aria we're gonna
be swapping sexy oh yes what did you
wear probably like I think I did a Mia
Wallace thing which I know is like duck
tried and true but I try to go for that
cuz it's like sexy without being like
overtly sexy but it's inherently sexy
because it's gonna Thurman I tend not to
go for the sexy thing anymore I think
when I was in college I did like a sexy
football player I like just wore Jersey
I I think it's fairly standard fare that
the female equivalent of a man's costume
is usually more revealing it has less
material it's crap honestly the females
costumes are like generally I feel like
worse quality and sometimes are more
expensive I'm nervous because I feel
like I would be seeing more of Aria
today that I ever have or cared to
before in the past give it a rocket I
will say I'm a little nervous for you
but I feel like you're gonna rise very
soon because you've got that confidence
looks like I pick a gondola looks like
it's gonna be a tight squeeze around the
old midriff you know yeah let's try
these on I'm really excited for this
[Music]
wow you look from labyrinth that means
to be honest with you you look kind of
fabulous I will say yeah I'm surprised
by how it's not that revealing I don't
think if I was a bosom as' woman oh yes
there might be more here but perfect
that you know it's not too bad not too
bad it's not as scandalous as I would
have thought mine came with no pants so
I had to wear half my jumpsuit okay
that's it look I thought that goes with
it yeah you look like a young young boy
oh dear okay so I didn't know what to do
with this thing and this was just a
loose ribbon you didn't seem sense and
you really should treat yourself I don't
know if I want to scream come on come on
all right at that you were you're great
you know if it's me pretty well yeah I
know you think you can keep that great
next costume oh yeah this is my next
look we're gonna match though we got the
orange which yours oh yeah I kind of
like her she looks she looks sweet she
looks like she's close to their family
okay let's try these on
ah hi like a Dutch woman you look like a
bit like a milkman or something you do
look like a pirate I do look like a bar
mate a barmaid yes I I have to say again
I don't feel like yours is particularly
revealing yeah not really no I don't
know man I just feel like I should be
holding an accordion or something I
don't know if I feel like a pirate Kyle
look at myself look like a scarecrow you
do you look like a pirate say say say
say say like you've got more going on
I've got costumes but I say in this case
the woman's costume is better I mean I
mean no the least attracted to you I've
ever been like that one's sexier for I
know that one's sexier let's see the
last one let's do a slap Casa Wow wine
is huge
would you ever had yours oh wow wow
she's it's it's a it's a jumpsuit I'm
mildly annoyed that the the picture has
a hat and an axe which I don't have
either okay you get a hat though I do
yeah I can't see the rest of my costume
though so it's gonna be a real surprise
oh there's no way to know okay let's put
on this last costume
conceal the attraction for me in this
costume pretty steadily I do say so
myself
I yeah it's kind of like this spell is
very good I don't he's not sexy like oh
no it's not you know it looks like a
crossing guard to me I think it maybe if
it was much much tighter on me
this is hot I feel like this is like I'm
ready to put out fires you legitimately
do look very much like a firefighter so
yeah I'm liking the jacket I like I look
a lot less like a crossbar than you oh
okay now you're a crossing guard that's
on their left leg just like about to
lose everything
this is actually yeah looks I would
think firefighter suspenders a nice
touch give you a lot of stuff our
costumes cost the same I'd say I got the
better end of evolute Lee yeah there's
the patriarchy at work I'm feeling
myself in this costume yeah it is
definitely the most attractive of the
three looks I've seen you keep it's very
loose I do I do it I don't understand
what this is
Oh hot fire department yours is hot -
hot hot stuff I didn't notice that wow
that was fun oh I feel shame about
costumes which is that they're pretty
poorly made and overpriced but the
woman's house is where he's revealing is
that I really was not quite as
compromised as I thought I was going to
be they didn't look like occupations
though they did not my I mean
technically that pirate one made me look
like a barmaid that's the wrong
occupation but ya know the fireman was
the best one pirate was the worst one
for me for you yeah the best of me you
know I really like the barmaid look
there was a lot of moving parts to it I
wasn't offended the firefighter costume
I think the first one my first one was
fabulous this year you look like a
housewife vampire like the real vampire
Elvira there you go I was ov era so
obviously one thing that we love about
Halloween is that it gives you the
chance to express yourself any way you
want maybe ways that you wouldn't the
rest of the year so you know you don't
actually have to buy a costume you could
just make one yourself
as someone that doesn't practice
Halloween I will say that I do
appreciate it as a time for everyone to
feel free to let their freaky flag fly
so this Halloween season go out there do
your thing eat some candy uh nah it's
fun Hollis I'm glad
show the spirits together yeah we got to
really get us each other in quite a
different light yeah I know what works
for your body type and what does not
likewise
[Music]